TED HAMILTON: Welcome to Find
The Next Big Thing with the
YouTube Analytics API.
I'm Ted Hamilton.
I'm the product manager for
YouTube Analytics out of our
Zurich office.
I'm here with Jeremy Walker, one
of our developer advocate.
And then Chris Schroeder, from
The Next Big Sound, who was an
early guinea pig-- an early
adopter for the YouTube
Analytics API.
So very quickly, I'll go
through, give you an
introduction of YouTube
analytics and what the API is
capable of doing.
Jeremy'll walk through
and actually show you
how to use the thing.
And then Chris is going to show
you the cool things that
they've actually done
with the API.
And then at the end, I'll come
back and talk a little bit
about what's ahead
for the API.
And then we'll
going into Q&A. So.
YouTube analytics.
Why does YouTube analytics
matter?
Historically, video has had very
little data around it.
You think, back in the day,
people would do screenings,
have surveys, have panels.
They'd put together a pilot
show and see how people
reacted to that.
And then make huge decisions
based on just this little
amount of information.
But right now, we're being
bringing absolute truckloads
of data to video.
We're bringing transparency
to the black box.
So, have most of you used
YouTube analytics?
Does this look familiar
to you?
Actually let's get
a show of hands.
How many people are actually
using are our API today?
How many are considering it?
And how many are just looking
for a good Wi-Fi signal?
All right.
That guy.
So yeah.
This is our overview page
in YouTube analytics.
Other things that we have,
we have maps of
average view duration.
We have break down of playback
locations and traffic sources.
We have the drop-off curves.
Where do people actually start
falling off of your videos?
Which parts do they
fast forward to?
Lots of really good stuff.
But what happens when you want
to do more than our UI offers?
What happens when--
your YouTube data's important,
but what about
your Facebook data?
Or your Twitter data?
What happens when you have
success metrics that are
different from the ones
that we offer?
Maybe you have some sort
of derived metric, like
subscribers per view.
Something like that.
Well, when you want to do more
than what our UI offers, you
do analytics API.
That's what you're
all here for.
Our API is broken down into
three main components.
They're the metrics.
Our big ones are views, minutes
watched, money, of
course, subscribers, and
then there's a whole
host of other things.
You could break these
down by date.
You get a time series
of these.
You can see how it's broken down
by geography, by content
entity, by channel or by video,
traffic source, et cetera.
And then, of course, you can
filter things down to only see
a specific date, date range,
specific geography, or one
particular video or channel.
And Jeremy, you want to
show us how to use it?
JEREMY WALKER: Sure.
Sure.
So, hi.
My name's Jeremy Walker.
I'm a YouTube Developer
Advocate.
And I'm going to jump into more
of the technical details
about how and why you want
to use the analytics API.
So how am I going to
show you guys this?
So what I'm going to do is,
I'm going to show you
something interesting I learned
from using the API.
And then I'm going to
show you an example.
So it's going to be a cycle.
Interesting insight,
how did I do it?
So I'm going to do
three use cases.
The first one will be popularity
by country.
So I'm going to show you some
videos I picked out on that.
Annotations, so how does
it overlays impact
your minutes watched?
And just so you guys know, I'm
pulling this information from
the Google Developers channel,
which is a channel we use to
teach about our APIs.
And I'm specifically focusing
on YouTube API videos.
And then, finally, what's the
best length for your video?
The age-old question, long
form versus short form.
So any of you that don't know,
short form is shorter videos.
And then long forms are much
longer videos, like half an
hour or whatever.
So I thought it'd be appropriate
to grab one of the
2012 talks that we
did on YouTube.
So what I did is, I set up a
script that ran through and
grabbed all the YouTube-related
I/O videos
last year, and displayed then
based on country and views.
And I actually grabbed
this one.
This is about the embeddable
YouTube upload widget, which
Jeff and Eric talked
about last year.
It just simplifies uploading
videos, among other things.
And what was actually kind of
interesting about it was how
the views broke down.
So I just took the top four.
And Russia and India were
about on par for views.
The US was actually about 48%
higher in views than Russia.
And Brazil was actually
about 14% higher in
views than the USA.
So why is it interesting?
Well, if you're making
this video, then
it's kind of important.
Because now you have this large
audience in Brazil and
Russia that maybe you didn't
even know about.
So then you start thinking of
ways, how can I incorporate
them into my videos so that
I can continue that growth
that's happening, maybe without
much work that I'm
doing on my side?
Now what's really interesting
about this is actually, the
video had little annotations
on it so you could click
through to the documentation.
So the next thing I did is I
grabbed the order of that.
And so third and fourth, the
lowest clickthrough rates were
the USA and India.
And then Russia was second.
And Brazil was first.
But what's really interesting is
the percentage differences.
So Russia, actually, they were
27% more likely to click
through than the USA.
So that's kind of interesting.
And then Brazil was
actually 55% more
likely to click through.
So again, what does
this all mean?
What does it mean to you?
So if you're the owner
of the video, then
you're thinking, OK.
Top three countries, I've got
Brazil, USA, and Russia.
And then the clickthrough rates
are Brazil and Russia.
And they're way higher
than the USA.
So what's that mean?
Well, in Brazil they speak
Portuguese, and not a lot of
people necessarily know
English there.
So maybe they're very interested
in the subject
matter, but they don't
understand it.
So they have to click through to
read or have it translated
through there.
So same with Russia.
So what could you do?
You could put some budget aside
and have some captions
added for Portuguese
and Russian.
And then you could take it a
step further and start pulling
minutes watched to see
if that's increasing
your minutes watched.
Because that's what a lot
of people measure
their success on.
So that's just one
of the use cases.
So you can see there, that's
pretty interesting.
And that would be
very powerful to
know for a video creator.
So how did I pull this
information?
Well first, I'm going to
do a high-level view of
how to get a report.
So first off, you need to
authorize and authenticate.
So you can't just get a
channel's information.
You have to sign in
and do that stuff.
But we have a way to authorize
that through OAuth 2.0.
And then you can authenticate
through an access token.
Next you'll want to get
your channel ID.
So the channel ID is this long
string of characters, that--
it's like, nobody has
it memorized.
I don't.
So you hit up the YouTube data
API, which is another API
which you use for general stuff
that you do on YouTube.
Specifically we just need
the channel ID.
And then use the analytics
API to get your report.
So first, I'm going to show
you guys the API explorer.
Not a lot of people use this.
Well, not enough people
use this yet.
It's a great tool.
As a best practice, you should
always use this before you
write any code.
Because you'll find that you
resolve most of your code
problems here first, before
you move it over.
I work on the analytics API with
people that work on it.
And a lot of people have trouble
saying, oh, this
library has a bug in it.
But they're trying to run a
report that doesn't exist, or
it doesn't work together.
So it's always a good idea
to do this first.
You don't have to
write any code.
And it lets you do everything
to start with.
And then you can import that
right over to your code.
So I'm actually going
to show you that.
Let me pull up an
example here.
OK.
So I've been talking
about my channel--
or the YouTube channel-- but I
wanted to show you guys some
extra information as well.
I have my own channel,
which has some
mildly popular videos.
Well, that's probably blowing
it up a little bit.
But anyway, I did run some of
my own reports to see how it
was doing, to see if there's
any countries that were
interested in my content.
So by the way, to find this API
explorer, just do a search
for Google API explorer.
You choose YouTube
Analytics API.
Or you can search YouTube
Analytics API, and we've got
it right there on one
of the pages.
So anyway, you authenticate
here--
or, sorry, authorize.
And this should go up.
And then you can see here,
this is a channel report.
So this is what I would
get from the data API.
And then I would just put in
dates, views, and then I do
the dimension country.
And then in this case, I'm
guarding this video ID, which
is the video I'm trying to do.
So let's see here.
OK.
So what am I getting
back here?
I'm getting a JSON back.
You can get a CSV back.
But the values, country
and then views.
And so in January of 2012, you
can see in Bulgaria this video
got 4,500 views.
And in the USA it got 100.
Which is probably more
than my normal.
So why did it blow
up in Bulgaria?
Well, I don't know, but if I was
tracking this enough with
the APIs, I could get a aping
saying, hey, you're blowing up
in Bulgaria.
Go check it out.
And then you can say, whoa,
what's going on,
and then help that.
Maybe you could promote it even
more because you figured
out what's going on there.
Anyway.
So if you guys remember, when I
set these values here, just
look at these.
So, channel ID, date,
views, and country.
Now I'll flip back over
to my presentation.
And you'll see that when I
move to the code, wow, it
looks exactly the same, right?
I didn't show an annotation
clickthrough rate because I
didn't have one on that video.
But you get the idea.
You port these values almost
over exactly, and you're done.
So then you get your--
this is Java, but it could
be JavaScript or
whatever you want.
All right.
So let's go to another
example.
So we're at number two.
So, annotations, user
clickthrough--
this is the wrong
way to do it.
People will leave So
I did decide to
push it a little bit.
And what I did is, I took one
of our more popular YouTube
API videos, and I added an ugly
click through that was
pretty big.
So if you don't know, we have
a YouTube Android Player API
that lets you play videos in
your Android app so you don't
leave the experience.
Like Flipboard lets
you do that.
It's a really nice experience.
But I put this on there
to see what it would
do to minutes watched.
So I did it for seven days.
So seven days before,
it dropped almost
10% the minutes watched.
And then when I lifted
it, it went up 14%.
So I have no idea why it
went up 4 more percent.
Maybe you should put
an overlay and pull
it, and then your--
I don't know.
Anyway, this is pretty
interesting to me.
Because it shows,
well, does this
negatively impact your videos?
And some people would
say, well, yes.
For us, not really, because
what's our message?
We just want to educate
people on our APIs.
And maybe this drives them,
and they start reading the
documentation and start
coding in it.
But if you're doing this for
maybe entertainment or
something, maybe this wouldn't
be a good metric.
Which is what I'm going
to show you on
another one of my videos.
So I actually ran two.
I'm going to show you
a before and after.
I put a really ugly one
on one of my videos.
Just to see what
would happen--
again, I want to authorize--
to see what would happen
if I did this on mine.
So I added an ugly one
that had nothing
to do with the video.
And this video is not for
educational purposes.
It's more for entertainment.
You can see, really,
everything's the same, minus
the metrics.
I just change to estimated
minutes watched.
I just execute it.
You can see here's the request,
the response.
OK.
I have about 165 minutes
watched.
So again, that's for
the week before.
And then the week after--
again, don't forget
to authorize--
let's see what happens.
OK.
Wow.
I lost a half an hour just
by adding an overlay.
So people didn't like
the overlay on mine.
And so that's bad.
So overlays are bad for me.
Or annotations.
So anyway, if you look
at the code--
again, have a look.
Just remember this, dates,
estimated minutes
watched, the video ID.
And then if you look
at the code here,
it's the same thing.
So it's just quick port.
Really easy.
OK.
I've got one more example,
and then we'll be done.
So part of the Google Developers
channel, one of the
main things we do, is Google
Developers Live, which is a
live show we do once a week.
And what's interesting is, it
started like a year ago.
And we were doing an
hour-long show.
The first half was usually an
interview, and then we'd do
best practice.
And as time passed, we
were like, this is
probably too long.
Let's cut in half.
Let's split it out.
So then we started
doing either an
interview or best practices.
And then over time, we've kind
of narrowed it down and down.
So I thought, well, I'll grab
some numbers from some of
those videos, and see how the
minutes watched went.
Kind of the same metric I
grabbed in the last example,
but for a different use case.
So this video is 50 minutes.
And what happened was, when I
cut it in half, the minutes
watched went up 110%.
So people like shorter videos.
And then it actually went up
another 25% when we cut more
time off of it.
So shorter is better.
So we're still trying
to figure out the
optimum time for us.
We want to get the
message across.
So maybe we go down
a little bit more.
But this is interesting,
right?
If you're making video or doing
video production, less
work means more time people
watch, right?
So if we do less work,
we get more--
you see what I'm saying?
So this is pretty interesting.
Now, how did I get this?
It's the same report.
It's estimated minutes
watched.
And that's the same report,
so I probably won't
show that to you guys.
But you can pull it as
a content owner as
well, if you want.
If you have multiple channels,
we have another report type
where you can pull-- you may
own one or two or three
channels, and this allows you to
pull one of those or all of
them, separately or
all together.
And instead of channel ID you
just put content owner and
drop in your username there.
But you can see the report's
pretty much the same.
And if you want to find out a
little bit more on how to do
this, I did a pre-I/O
session--
it's about 10 minutes-- where I
walk through this made much
more detail.
Check that out.
It's on the Google Developer
channel.
All right, so those are
my three examples.
Hopefully you got something
out of it.
And now I'm going to turn it
over to Chris, who's going to
talk about pulling our data and
combining it with other
data to find even more
interesting insights.
CHRIS SCHROEDER: Awesome.
Thanks, Jeremy.
Hi, everyone.
My name is Chris Schroeder.
I'm an engineer at
Next Big Sound.
And right now, I'm going to talk
about the ways that our
company and our customers use
the YouTube Analytics API and
the data from the API.
So Next Big Sound tracks the
online activity for almost
every band in the world.
And we organize that data into
a centralized dashboard which
we provide back to the
music industry.
And our customers include both
individual bands and band
managers, who are trying
to grow their fan base,
understand their fan base,
and promote themselves.
As well as the record labels,
who invest heavily in
developing artists and
marketing artists.
And they want to back the
decisions they make up with--
they want to back up their
decisions with data and make
intelligent decisions.
So let's jump into our
first example.
We're going to look at data
for a well-established and
award-winning indie rock band.
And earlier this year, they
did a live television
appearance at an awards show
where they performed.
And now, if you're a label,
or you're the band, what's
important is understanding
the impact that you made.
You're not, probably,
getting paid to do
the performance itself.
What you're really interested
is in how it drives the
awareness around the band, and
how it drives people online to
take action and learn
about your band.
So this is a screen shot
from our product.
And what we're looking at here
is a graph over 90 days of
YouTube Analytic metrics.
90-day period around the key
event-- the awards show.
In this case, we've
selected three
YouTube Analytics metrics--
views, comments, and likes.
So over here on the right hand
side, you can see that what
we've done is overlay an event
stream for the artist.
So for each artist we're
tracking album releases, chart
appearances, as well as concert
performances and
activity on social
media platforms.
So in this case, you can see
that on Twitter and Facebook,
it's indicating to us that they
did, in fact, perform at
this awards show.
You can see from the dramatic
spike in the data in the
middle here that the appearance
was a success.
So in the days before the awards
show, the numbers were
around 150,000 views per day.
And then it jumped about 450%
percent the day after the show
to over a half a million
views in a single day.
So that's a lot of great
information.
You can also see here, earlier,
you can sort of tell
that there was buzz increasing
before the show and leading up
to show, and the band, and about
the two weeks prior.
So now, if you're the label,
as the next steps, what you
might want to do is compare
other artists that also
performed on this show.
Or other times your band, here,
performed on other TV
shows, and get a comparison.
So this is the sort of
data-driven approach that Next
Big Sound makes possible.
In the words of Forbes,
"Moneyball for music." And I
think that's a really
great analogy.
Because the same way that data
and analytics revolutionized
baseball, the same
thing's happening
in the music industry.
If you think about how much
the industry is changing--
the different ways people can
go online and consume music,
learn about bands, share
music, discover music--
as well as the different ways
artists can now connect
directly with fans, it's
really critical have a
platform like Next Big Sound
that gives you the data to
make sense of all
those signals.
And YouTube Analytics in
particular is very interesting
for our customers.
Not only on YouTube is there a
great way for fans to connect
with artists, but also it's
opening up new ways for
artists to become successful
and break.
Think about--
just recent examples--
the Harlem Shake, that meme, as
well as the viral video for
"Gangnam Style."
Also, a lot of artists, and
some labels, revenue from
YouTube is very significant
for them.
It's part of their
business model.
And then for record labels, also
being able to find and
develop talent in a new
way using YouTube.
YouTube analytics, in
particular, adds a new level
of granularity and detail to
the data that's available.
So the geographic and
demographic insights that
Jeremy was alluding to.
As well as new types of metrics
that are really
interesting--
unique views, comments,
shares, and
also watch time metrics.
And by bringing all that data
into the Next Big Sound
platform, as an artist, you're
able to compare yourself to
similar artists or competitive
artists, as well as, maybe,
artists that you're aspiring
towards, that are kind of like
a role model for your band.
Then also do cross-network
comparisons, and be able to
look at YouTube Analytics data
alongside metrics and events
from other social networks.
And so, in addition to YouTube,
we're collecting from
a wide variety of sources.
Just real quick.
Social media sources.
Internet radio.
Terrestrial radio.
Sales data from our customer,
including iTunes and digital
downloads from Amazon as well.
So it's a wide variety
of data.
Very unique data set that we
have, and very valuable.
So let's look at another
example,
this time for geography.
We're looking at the
geographic data.
Three different YouTube
Analytics metrics
for the same artist.
And this artist is an
up-and-coming British pop singer.
And she's popular in the UK,
and their team is trying to
break her into the US market.
And so that's the story
that's happening here.
Interestingly, on the left
hand side, if we look at
views, the highest percentage
of views for her is still
coming from the United
Kingdom.
But if we look at new fans, or
the subscribers metric, you
can see that the highest
percentage is coming from the
United States.
Also, likes, which is a form of
engagement, is also coming
in the highest percentage
in the United States.
So the story that's being told
here matches up with the
efforts that her team
are working on.
So it's good signals for them.
Here's an example using
the same demographic--
excuse me, demographics for the
same artist, but on two
different social networks.
So this artist is a well-known,
established jazz
and pop singer who has several
number one albums.
He's got mass appeal across a
wide variety of audiences.
But interestingly, in this case,
in the social network on
the left, his fan base skews
heavily female in
the 18 to 24 range.
Whereas on YouTube, on the left,
his fan base is much
more evenly distributed.
So this is really useful
information in terms of what
type of content the singer and
his team is going to post to
these different networks.
And so it's really good
information to have.
YouTube data is also allowing us
to give key insights to the
music industry.
So our data analytics
team-- excuse me.
The question in this case that
we're trying to address is the
relationship between social
media and sales.
Is there a relationship,
and what's that like?
So our data science team did
an analysis on iTunes sales
and radio spins compared to key
social media metrics from
a variety of the
major networks.
And so, a couple of findings.
One of the key ones is
very interesting.
It's that when you look that
values for the same day, the
highest correlation of any
social media metric to sales,
or to track sales specifically,
was YouTube.
Number one on this list
is radio spins.
That's sort of been the de facto
standard in the industry
for forecasting sales.
So to see YouTube plays right
up there with it is
a really good sign.
And so the suggestion here
is that consumers
are going on YouTube.
And they're learning about the
tracks from YouTube that they
plan on possibly buying next.
And so the message is that it's
very important to have
high-quality YouTube content
with your artist.
So just to share a little bit
about our own experiences
working with the API.
The API is extremely flexible.
It felt like everything that was
available on the YouTube--
excuse me, on the users'
analytics dashboard was also
available through the API.
And working with it was
very straightforward.
Are off to integration in the
standard our data collector is
simply a Java app with a
standard HTTP client.
And everything's formatted
in JSON.
So there's no surprises there.
Basically, everything worked
as advertised.
For us, one thing to note,
your auth tokens.
They can expire pretty
frequently.
So it's important to refresh
them and handle those types of
connection errors that you get
that are going to be common.
Just kind of nature of
working with an API.
Probably our biggest challenge
working with the API was just
how we constructed
our queries, and
being mindful of that.
Basically, we're collecting
a wide variety of data.
Daily values for many metrics
for each video associated with
the channel for each artist.
Also, with geo-granularity.
So for us, we learned that
breaking down the data by
geography as well as by day
in the same query, you
can't really do.
And certain metrics also don't
get combined well in the API.
So you just have to be mindful
of that, and be careful about
the number of queries
you end up making.
And being careful not to
use too much quota.
So for us, we're
really excited
About the scheduled reports'
bulk data feature that the
YouTube team has been
telling us about.
And lastly, just a
couple of tips.
I'd say, reiterating what Jeremy
mentioned, that YouTube
API explorer is awesome.
It's really cleared
up any mystery
around how the API works.
It really should be your best
friend when you're working
with the API.
And also, post questions
to Stack Overflow.
Because the team gets back
to you pretty quickly.
And it's really been
a help for us, too.
Great.
Let me pass it back to Ted.
Thank you.
TED HAMILTON: Thanks.
That was awesome.
All right, so what's
next for us?
Devices.
Yes.
Very shortly, you'll
see a device report
appear in our UI.
And then shortly thereafter,
it'll be available in the API.
So you can finally see the
trends of how quickly people
are moving to mobile, and what
different viewing behaviors
people have on different
devices.
We'll also break it down
by operating system.
So you can see if there's a
material difference based on
what app people are
using, et cetera.
Audience retention.
So our audience retention curves
are very useful, but
have not been available
for the API ever.
We will make sure to
add that soon.
And then lastly, bulk data.
So our API right now is designed
around point queries.
You ask a very specific question
and we give you a
specific answer.
This is great for dashboards,
great for apps, et cetera.
But when you have the data
warehousing use case, where
you actually just want to
transfer all of that data over
into your database,
you have to ask a
lot of queries, right?
And this uses a lot of quota.
So we wanted to build a way that
you can actually schedule
a query, we process it offline,
and then you can just
download all of it.
This has been a big, long ask.
But in general, we want the API
to have every bit of the
capability that the UI has,
and even go beyond that.
In an ideal world, we would be
exposing data through our API
before even makes
it into our UI.
So, thank you very much.
We now have some time
for questions.
If you have a question, please
use a microphone so we can
catch it on our recording.
MARK: Thanks, guys.
Great presentation.
My name is Mark.
I come from Pixability
in Boston.
Do you have a time frame
on the bulk data thing?
Because multi-dimensional
queries would be brilliant.
TED HAMILTON: Yeah, so
it's always tough.
Things that you think would be
very quick can tend to have
problems, et cetera.
So I can't get anything
very specific.
But it is very high on
the priority list.
So I would hope sometime later
in the summer or in the fall,
we would have that available.
MARK: And if you need anyone to
try it out first, I'm quite
happy to do that.
TED HAMILTON: Great.
Yeah.
Talk to me afterwards.
We can take your name down.
Anybody else?
AUDIENCE: Bulk data,
[INAUDIBLE]--
TED HAMILTON: Can you please
use the microphone?
AUDIENCE: So bulk data, can
you give a little bit more
perspective on quotas, method
of access, et cetera?
TED HAMILTON: No.
Not really too much.
We haven't gotten to that
stage of planning.
But it should be--
if we can process this offline,
and then you can just
download it.
You're not hitting our servers
to do any processing.
So it should alleviate a lot
of the quota pains that you
guys are having.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
How are you doing?
Any of the new data points going
to require additional
scope requests?
TED HAMILTON: Sorry, can you
repeat the question?
AUDIENCE: Are any of the new
data points that you're going
to release going to require
additional scope requests from
the content owner?
I don't know.
Christophe, actually.
Do you have an answer
to that question?
Christophe, in the crowd
here, is our lead
developer on the API.
JEREMY WALKER: Have him
use the microphone?
AUDIENCE: OK.
And then, related to that, do
you guys have any plans to
allow us to do analytics for
channels for which we don't
have credentials, but
who are giving away
the analytics anyway?
TED HAMILTON: So actually,
could I ask you to first
repeat the answer for the people
on the recording of
what Christophe told you?
AUDIENCE: Sure.
He said everything would
be available
under the current scopes.
TED HAMILTON: OK, great.
And so the answer of the
question of, will we be giving
out more public data?
Philosophically, yes.
This is something that
would be marvelous.
If people are willing to
contribute their data so other
people can learn, that's
something that we
would want to enable.
That's probably not on the
priority list for this year.
But definitely, that's
a direction that we
would like to head.
All right.
If there are no more questions,
we actually will be
in the sandbox just down
the hall here.
Go down and to the right
is the YouTube sandbox.
We'll be there right after
this presentation.
And actually, I have been
hanging out there
for most the time.
So if you have any questions
you didn't want to ask in
front of everyone or didn't
think of it right away, just
come by and visit us,
and we'd be happy
to answer your questions.
All right.
Thank you very much.